[inaudible]
joining me today as a fellow at the Manhattan Institute,
a self described secular,
conservative and the author of the diversity delusion.
Heather McDonald.
Finally,
welcome to the Rubin report.
I'm so grateful to be here.
Thank you so much Dave.
I don't know how this hasn't happened already.
How did we not,
you're on the road all the time.
You're a hard man to connect with.
We've been on the road together.
We did.
We did Berkeley together and we survived.
Surprisingly,
uh,
attentive and polite crowd.
Uh,
it's kind of a disappointment actually.
You know,
we had dinner
before and we were like,
oh,
you know,
it'll be fine if we got some protest because there's a nice amount of protesters
where it can be enjoyable.
Then there's like the circus amount where it's not fun anymore.
But we were kind of like,
oh,
we'll get some.
And we got a few,
but nothing,
nothing much in.
Of course,
they're so stupid,
they don't realize it in protesting somebody.
They're just increasing the visibility.
So yeah,
if they really want to destroy all,
all Ali conservative opposition,
they should just stay quiet,
you know?
And let us fade into the woodwork.
On that note,
we'll spend the next hour trying to gin up some opposition to your ideas.
Let's do it.
Okay.
So first off,
uh,
I came to know about you when you spoke or you were to speak at Claremont
Mckenna University back in 2017 and you were going to give a talk on black lives
matter.
And why don't you just tell the people what happened?
Because that was the first time I found out who you are.
Well,
I was gonna talk about the fact that there is enormous support for the police in
minority communities.
I've spent a lot of time in police community meetings in Harlem and South
Central La.
And for what I hear from those good people is that we want more cops.
We want the drug dealers off the corner.
I smelled pot in my cord.
Or why can't you do something about it?
There's kids hanging out,
fighting whatever happened to truancy and loitering laws.
Uh,
and so I was going to present a different narrative from the black lives matter
narrative.
A few days before my,
uh,
scheduled talk,
a call went out on Facebook to shut the fascist white supremacist homophobe
queer for Muslim folk down.
We will not allow the fascist racist Mcdonald to have a platform.
So initially they thought they'd move the venue because where I was speaking had
too many plate glass windows.
They decided to keep it in what's called the Athenaeum.
Uh,
but I was put into what was essentially a safe house on campus waiting for my
talk.
I could hear the drumming and the chanting grow louder and louder.
I couldn't see what was going on.
It was a disconcerting experience.
Yeah.
Uh,
and I was escorted into the room,
uh,
with a police escort through a hidden tunnel.
I did not know at the time that about 200 students had surrounded the building
to prevent anybody from entering to attend the talk.
So I spoke to an empty room.
Uh,
the police were inside the building.
At some point they decided that they couldn't guarantee my safety and longer,
cause people were pounding on the plate glass windows.
So I was taken out the kitchen with police escort into a waiting police car and
zipped away.
So I asked you this,
not because I know you don't want to play the Wii.
No,
I don't.
I really don't.
But it's what I think it's important for people to realize that this has
happened to so many people who I know,
including me.
And actually I'm very proud to say that I spoke at Claremont Mckenna a few
months after in that in that very room,
and they made it very clear that the whole point of the night was that they
never wanted what happened to you to repeat again.
So they actually did do what a university is supposed to do,
but just can you tell me,
I mean,
you strike me as a totally lovely,
pleasant person that,
that,
that people have connections that people have the,
they just make up what you think and that then you're treated like this.
It's just not fun.
Right?
I mean to put it mildly fun at,
you know,
it really is some,
cause we can joke about it like,
oh,
we love it and protests or from,
you know,
whatever.
But yeah.
Well with mobs you don't know what's going to happen next.
Yeah.
And again,
I am so reluctant to say anything that can be attributed to a victim ideology
because that is used against me.
But I did have a remote sense of what it feels like,
what felt like to be in the French revolution and hearing the mob because people
in crowds can become completely irrational.
Um,
so,
you know,
I,
I don't know that they're making up who I am because I,
well,
I certainly am not against black lives,
but my message to them as they understand it is tantamount to being against
black people.
And,
and what,
what this,
the groundwork for this insane delusion that is used against speakers is an even
crazier idea,
which is that students on college campuses today are at literal threat of their
lives from circa manbient,
racism and sexism.
This is a,
a delusional idea that is put into these students' heads sort of k through 12
because the identity politics is happening sooner and sooner,
but it is certainly reinforced by diversity bureaucrats on campus that are in a
codependent relationship with these narcissistic students who want to elevate
their status into the top dog victim on campus.
You know,
it's funny,
I did a talk at University of New Hampshire and protestors were,
were screaming at me in the middle and disrupting me and they have no problem
using their free speech to infringe on your first speech.
Of course.
Um,
and one of the,
somebody started screaming that we could be killed when we walk out of here.
I thought,
we're in the middle of New Hampshire.
Nobody's getting killed when you walk out of here.
And certainly if you don't behave in any criminal behavior,
absolutely nothing is.
But they've concocted a story in their mind and it's very hard to deconstruct a
story for these people.
Yeah,
I guess so.
Because again,
we're in a very weird position in our culture generally where the classical
virtues,
venerated strength and accomplishment,
perhaps to a fault,
you know,
because you had warrior cultures and for,
for centuries the main calling for males for accomplishment was war.
Uh,
but the classical virtues again celebrated heroism.
We now we're in a very strange position.
It's culture where we venerate victims.
And so if you can Eric gate to yourself some victim status,
and certainly the burgeoning category of gender identity is a mark of these
students,
desperate to find one final way of being transgressive that will not be
immediately assimilated into a new dirt diversity Synacor.
Uh,
but they are,
there's no way they're going to give up that sacred,
rarefied status of victim.
Uh,
and again,
there's nothing more tolerant than an an American college campus if,
if you're not challenging the orthodoxy.
But this is the most tolerant environment in human history for society's
traditionally marginalized groups.
It actively celebrates those traits that can still get you stoned or killed
elsewhere.
So to think,
you know,
as Brown students said,
occupying the president's office,
well it was hard for them to go to classes because they were focused so hard on
staying alive at Brown.
It's similar to New Hampshire.
I mean,
yeah,
this is,
this is certifiably insane thinking.
Yeah.
And unfortunately there aren't enough brave professors right.
To push back on this and then it becomes this self fulfilling thing because then
the teachers start feeding into it and the whole thing.
So before we go too deep on that,
and I want to,
I want to do all your greatest hits here because you have,
you have no fear talking about really what I think are the hot button issues of
the day.
But you described yourself as a secular conservative.
And that is not a phrase that I hear very often.
And as I've,
you know,
as I come from the left and I still consider myself liberal as I've been more
embraced by say,
conservatives,
um,
a lot of people that knew me from way back when they'll go out,
but Reuben there,
they're just waiting to turn on you because they're,
they're really religious.
They don't really like the gays and whatever else.
Um,
so can you sort of describe how you came to a place that you described yourself
as a secular conservative cause?
I don't think people really think that exists.
Well I guess I was always secular.
I wasn't always conservative.
Um,
I would have secular mean to you.
First off,
I'm very unreligious.
I am,
I to be honest,
probably,
um,
perhaps to fanatically unreligious I,
I simply do not agree with the idea that we're,
uh,
overseen by a personal loving God.
I find petitionary prayer,
a completely narcissistic activity that anybody would dare think that a personal
God would care about his cancer when there are people being mowed down in
earthquakes and landslides,
what I call the daily slaughter of the innocence,
again,
on a basis.
So,
uh,
I grew up not in a religious environment,
um,
and never even really thought about religion.
To me,
it's an interesting,
I can retroactively look at my experience growing up and,
and be sort of amazed at it.
It is a verification of what religious people talk about with the bi coastal
elites.
Cause I grew up in La,
I went to a lot of schooling and the east coast.
So I was in kind of a liberal of the culture.
I don't recall knowing anybody who was religious.
Okay.
Until I came to New York in the nine days and started thinking of myself
realizing that I was conservative because I'd always been a liberal by default.
And in that environment,
especially with national view,
I started meeting religious people for the first time.
Uh,
what did they make of a secular concern?
Even if you were liberal in the classical sense,
but let's say a burgeoning conservative at that point.
What did they make of a secular person?
Well,
I guess my first point is about this was,
was for the American conservative.
And I just wrote a piece saying,
you know,
the Republicans and conservatives who are so closely yoking conservative
ideology with religious belief are making a mistake.
Because I know a lot of very smart conservatives who are not themselves
believers either.
And to say that the only way you can be moral is to believe in God,
uh,
I think is a mistake.
So I then had participated in at founded in a blog called secular,
right.
That was founded by received Khan and,
and others.
Uh,
and I never was,
I was never a pariah or drummed out of the movement at all.
I got some sort of a sarcastic comments from major figures like,
so how's that?
Eighth Youth is ism thing going Heather.
Right.
Um,
but I,
I can't say that I was ever really,
uh,
punished for it,
but I think I was regarded as a,
uh,
a curiosity.
Yeah.
So obviously we're going to talk about so much of what's wrong with the
postmodern left and the progressive's,
but let's just talk a little bit about what's going on with the right these days
or let you know broadly,
let's say the conservatives,
the old school liberals,
the Libertarians resume.
I'm finding it to be the center,
right?
Let's say an extremely open group of people who are really willing to do this
dive into ideas and,
and agree to disagree in all of that.
How have you always found it to be that way?
Well,
again,
I have,
I mean,
I know you're saying you got a little,
a bit of push back let's say,
or did some joking about.
Yeah,
that just joking.
It was not malicious and it was not really serious.
Um,
yes,
I guess so.
Again,
I've,
I'm,
I consider myself kind of a latecomer to the right.
Uh,
but I've,
I don't think it was ever closed minded.
I think it's now maybe more self consciously open just because of the growing
totalitarianism on the left.
So perhaps people are extra careful to uh,
you know,
make sure that they're not excluding anybody,
but,
but I don't,
I think if you're trying to push back against some kind of stereotype that the
right is a bunch of,
of a closed minded bigots I've never experienced,
I just don't see it anywhere.
Right.
It's actually quite staggering to me.
Um,
okay.
So let's,
let's just plow through a whole bunch of topics.
So we touched a little bit on policing already and the black community.
Is there anything else you wanted to add to that?
Generally?
Well,
just the black lives merit of a matte black lives matter narrative is false and
stop.
We are not living through an epidemic of racially biased police shootings of
black men.
These core flaw of any left wing anti cop,
uh,
rhetoric or the mass incarceration meme is the failure to find the proper
benchmark for evaluating police behavior.
Uh,
inevitably policing is compared to population ratios.
So let's say in New York City,
uh,
about 50% of all pedestrian stops are of blacks.
Blacks are about 23% of the population of black lives matter activist or an
academic often would say that shows the police are racist,
wrong benchmark.
The benchmark is crime.
Policing is crime driven.
Blacks in New York City commit 71% of all shootings.
If you add Hispanic shootings to black shootings,
you account for 98% of all shootings in New York.
Whites are 34% of the population they commit to percent of shootings.
So,
so that's the basic fallacy that,
and this is a broader problem,
right?
So what would you say is the root of the root of this?
Is that I think the core difference between a liberal outlook on the world in a
conservative one is that liberals will only accept structural explanations for
socioeconomic disparities.
They will not ever accept a behavioral explanation that there are behaviors,
cultures that are different that explain poverty rates,
say conservatives maybe to a fault are not particularly open to structural
explanations.
And we'll see behavioral,
uh,
reasons.
So for instance,
when you look at poverty,
the biggest driver in American poverty today is having children out of wedlock.
If you are a single mother,
uh,
the chances are really high that you're going to be poor and your child is about
five times more likely to be poor than if he were a child of married parents.
Um,
and there's a whole set of choices for good or bad that people can make that
almost guarantee that you can become middleclass.
It's very simple.
Three simple things you can do,
uh,
graduate from high school.
Wait until you're married to have a child and work at a job full time.
Any job,
low minimum wage job.
73% of people who do that are not poor.
So that to me is the basic difference.
So the benchmark problem in policing comes from not being willing to look at
behavior and,
and I think that is true for everything in in society.
We have the most dangerous can seed out.
There is this disparate impact analysis that says that any neutral policy that
has a disparate impact on racial groups must be biased.
Again,
that is a analysis that only makes sense if you don't look at behavior.
So why the certain narratives then get sold much more than other narratives.
I have my own theories on this,
but why?
Why is the narrative out there that the police are racist?
I mean I did the media all collude to decide the same thing and put it out
there.
I mean really had is how do those,
how do those bad ideas than spread?
Well,
one thing,
I don't think it's happening.
I always get us,
is this all sorrows?
Yeah,
I don't think it is.
Everybody wants human beings like want agency,
right?
We want to answer one answer and they want to believe that everything is like
from top down.
I don't think it's so us money,
but I think there are memes that spread and I think there are ideologies and I
think that American culture now is very uncomfortable with inner city culture,
with uh,
certain dysfunctional minority culture and doesn't,
don't want to talk about it.
We want to turn our eyes away from it and we have the most appalling history of
racism in this country.
It is really unthinkable how blind we were to the profound hypocrisy that
governs so much of our politics for so long.
You know,
one when can't begin to understand how,
how that could not have been obvious.
But I think our degree of guilt for that is now so great and understandable
frankly,
that we're very reluctant to ascribe agency to blacks.
We want to say everything,
the continuing problems,
the failure to close the achievement gap,
the crime disparities,
which are massive.
The victimization disparities,
blacks die of homicide at six times the rate of whites and Hispanics combined.
That's a civil rights problem,
but nobody wants to talk about that.
Instead,
we want to change the narrative to be,
it's all white racism,
which is a way of infantilizing blacks of saying there's nothing you can do for
yourselves.
Getting rid of the acting white culture,
you know,
emulate like we should all emulate Asians.
I've,
I pose a thought experiment.
If blacks acted like Asians for 10 years in all things the same like negligible
rate of out of wedlock child rearing,
the same fanatical involvement in schools,
you know,
drive parents'll drive study,
you're going to go to Harvard,
you know,
nothing is acceptable.
Don't go to Harvard if you're a these dries.
That's right.
Well,
you're going to have to be 10 times greater than any better than anybody else to
go to Harvard and you will be right.
If,
if,
if the behaviors were the same and we still saw these socioeconomic disparities,
then I will entertain institutional structural racism and as,
as an explanation.
But as long as the behaviors are so vastly different in in California where we
are now,
the truancy rate for blacks is five times higher than any other ethnic group.
As long as those behaviors are so different.
I think it's premature to say the only possible explanation is structural
racism.
Do you think this is also that we just have this sort of self fulfilling
prophecy now between the media and our politicians?
So like right as we're taping this right now,
the La school teachers are on strike and it's like,
well,
wait a minute,
I see all these lefties on Twitter,
everyone complaining and teachers need more money and blah blah,
except it's all progressive's that run in California in la forever.
So it's like these are your guys that have been putting in all these policies
that the teachers are upset by that.
But it's that they just,
the answer's always easy.
It's just more money,
more money,
more money and that,
and that makes people feel good because it's always easy to say,
oh well just give it more money.
And then the media does this same thing too,
where it's just,
it's racism,
it needs more money and that there's no actual,
well,
they're substantive debate.
It's happening online now,
but not sort of in the places that it should happen.
Do you see politicians having these discussions?
Honestly,
anywhere or,
well,
no,
I mean I think,
again,
nobody wants to talk about individual agency.
Nobody wants to talk about it's behavioral choices.
And you know,
this gets to something we've briefly touched on before,
which is the debate around Tucker Carlson and,
and him.
It was a very odd moment.
I mean,
I,
I love Tucker,
but he's taking basically a left wing position,
which is that,
you know,
the plight of rural America or the opioid crisis of the disengagement of males,
uh,
from the workforce,
which is a very serious thing is a result of economic policy.
And there's been people who've been pushing back against that on national view.
David French.
Yeah.
This is just in the last 10 days.
Right.
And I think if a persuasive way,
which is to say,
well,
you're doing the same kind of a shift of responsibilities.
It's traditionally the left does,
which is to say,
well,
it's these large social forces.
No,
we'll actually,
again,
even if we've got jobs moving off off shore,
they're still are individual choices that people can make that vastly increased
their chances of success.
Again,
do not have children out of wedlock study,
do not get involved in drugs,
don't become a pothead.
These are all within individual agency.
Obviously the left doesn't want to acknowledge that because there is some sort
of interest in expanding bureaucracies to deal with this function.
Mean.
I've seen this,
I've written a lot about uh,
Hispanics in California and spent time in,
uh,
the Brendas school in Pico Rivera middle school,
which is just crawling with gang counselors and pregnancy counselors for the
social dysfunction that's happening with the second third generation Hispanics.
But the bureaucracy grows larger and larger every place,
uh,
as a substitute for saying to individuals,
you know,
pull up your bootstraps and you can do it yourself.
Yeah,
there's an odd thing where then the conservatives and the libertarians who are
against authoritarianism by nature need a little bit of authoritarian structure,
so to speak.
I had a Catherine verbal sing in here who's a school administrator in the UK,
was taking,
she,
uh,
she was a teacher in the inner city in London and she realized how dysfunctional
everything that you're talking about was in the breakdown of the family.
And these kids,
they were malnutritioned and they had no rights.
They behaved horribly and all these things and now she started her own school.
Then mckayla school and I went there and these kids in inbetween classes,
they have to walk exactly in line.
They can't speak during lunch.
They can only talk about one topic and there's a,
you know,
any one could be called on at any given moment and I thought this is so bizarre
because here this is the right kind of authoritarianism with younger people.
I thought that that's actually pretty cool.
You got to get them young though,
right?
Right.
Structure.
I mean this is,
there's charter schools in the United States like Kipp that do the same thing.
You know,
everything is scripted because the families are so dysfunctional.
Now again,
predominantly single mothers,
although there's obviously,
let me just put in the disclaimer,
there are heroic single mothers out there who are doing the right thing by their
children,
but I'm sorry.
On average I'm not talking about you individual.
I'm talking on average ear.
It's the worst thing you could do for your kid not to have the father at the
home,
but yes,
this is the last chance these kids have to get socialized and the tragedy,
again,
to bring back to the disparate impact idea,
something that we've just been going through with with Trump's education
secretary,
the Obama administration had this idea that was already bubbling on the
progressive left in education schools that if black kids are disciplined more
than white kids,
that must be because of teacher racism.
Again,
you are not allowed to look at behavior.
This is the key.
The left will never look at behavior,
and so the fact that black kids commit homicide at 10 times the rate black
teenagers between the ages of 14 and 17 commit homicide at 10 times the rate of
white and Hispanic male teens combined according to federal data w on Thomas
side,
which is the gold standard.
I mean there's,
there's nothing like,
you know,
at all a wiggle room in this data,
that type of disparity and socialization that leads to those types of homicide
disparities shows up in the classroom as well as any inner city kid can tell
you.
Uh,
the Obama rule said you may not discipline black kids more and as a result,
kids are running a muck in schools.
They're attacking their,
basically,
you just put these arbitrary rules in that clearly don't fit what is actually
happening,
but it makes you feel good.
It makes you blame whites,
everything.
It's all the product of white racism.
Hmm.
So,
so yes,
I'm all for informal structure.
If a family cannot do what I mean Aristotle,
again,
this gets back to the secular right thing.
I hear that people say,
well,
how do you raise a moral kid without religion?
Aristotle said,
virtue is habit.
And I,
I don't know,
I was not raised and we'll just family,
but isn't really the case that a parent says to his five year old son,
don't hit your three year old brother because Jesus said not too,
or is it just do not hit your,
your three year old brother.
You know?
I think the authority from parental authority is sufficient and you acclimate
children to a set of behaviors that are self controlling,
deferring gratification by just teaching.
This is how we behave and through the inculcation of habit.
I don't think in raising children,
I just can't imagine at what point you need to invoke the 10 commandments.
I think that a lot of these behaviors,
the golden rule is something that can't talked about as something that is pretty
innate to a understanding that humans develop of what is needed to function in a
relatively civil society.
Yeah.
I have to tell you,
this is such an example of why I love doing this show,
because just an hour before sitting down with you,
I don't know if you know him,
but I had a Dr. Everett Piper on who's the president of Oklahoma Wesleyan
University [inaudible] and you guys probably agree on politics at like 99% and
yet he's religious and a lot of what we talked about was from a religious
perspective.
But that to me is that that's the beauty of what America is all about.
It's like actually on the things that,
that matter outside of what your personal beliefs are.
You're agreeing on all this stuff and then you have some differences on
existential questions and yeah,
so be it.
Well,
and,
and it's also something that we're now playing with fire of being able to
disagree amicably.
I mean,
I don't know if we should all be like screaming,
you know,
send in the,
the fire alarm or that they're the firetrucks,
but this growing civil violence that is predominantly on the left.
Obviously Charlottesville was an abomination.
But I would say in terms of sheer numbers of incidents,
obvious we the the the right,
the alt right,
the craziest took a life,
which is a game changer.
I mean that's qualitatively different than anything.
Then,
you know,
following round Tucker Carlson or screaming at Trump officials.
Nevertheless,
uh,
the antifa violence is,
is playing with tribal hatreds in a way that I think is extremely naive if we
think that America is permanently immune from the type of violence it's still
characterize as other societies.
Yeah.
No buddy on the left seems to know,
first off,
CNN ignores it basically,
and then the politicians don't say anything about it.
Okay.
So let's,
let's link this to one of the other things that you talk about a lot,
which is sort of what's happening right now very,
very intensely,
which seems like this new war on men or war on boys.
So how,
how is this related to two?
It's related sort of in the interracial context,
especially if you're talking about young black men,
but we can,
we can separate those two things a little bit if you want.
Well,
females are determined to think of themselves as victims to a,
which is preposterous.
There is not a single mainstream institution in the society,
whether it's a university,
a bank,
a law firm,
a government agency,
a foundation,
k through 12 that is not,
well k through 12 probably not because there you've got a super abundance of
females,
but,
but every mainstream institution is trying to hire and promote as many females
as possible.
I know for sure,
I just,
it's just inevitable that I have been the so called beneficiary of gender
preferences continuously.
You know,
there's a,
there's no good you admitted,
you know?
No,
it disgusts me frankly.
Uh,
you know,
there's now this whole meme about manels a,
thou shalt not put together a scientific panel of the top cancer researchers.
If it happens to be all males,
you must put females on that panel.
This is crazy.
Yeah.
Who Cares?
I really do not care who solves Alzheimer's.
If it's all females,
because they're the best.
So be it.
But if it's all males,
I don't give a damn.
Are you telling me that if you had heart surgery you would want,
I got to check out what the best surgeon regardless of their sexuality or gender
or skin color or kind of big adore you.
I don't know.
I guess I'm just blind to the truth prevails of females,
you know,
and,
and look at again,
females now or at least at parody.
It's very curious.
All the institutions that have a super abundance of females,
nobody ever thinks to say,
well there must be anti male bias,
you know,
but anything or something.
I see,
I see.
And it's also the case,
you know,
in academia if anybody says,
well there's these vast disparities of liberals to conservatives in academia,
which I frankly think it's kind of a side issue.
I David Horwitz.
Yes.
David Horwitz Taught,
tells a story about going to Columbia in the 1950s and being taught by Marxists,
but it didn't matter because mostly politics stayed out of the classroom,
but they were open minded.
And my ideal of education as frankly a pure ivory tower,
I think everybody should just be reading Edmund Spencer's,
the fairy queen and Milton.
And Trollope and wallowing and pastoral poetry.
I think I shouldn't be even fun.
I don't,
I should be invited to a college campus because me talking about policing is,
is of the wisps of,
of the,
of transitory reality that they'll get too.
There's time enough after you graduate.
These are four precious years to take a deep dive into beauty,
into grand.
You're into sublimity,
into wit and to irony into the greatest expressions of mankind,
not into contemporary politics are homeless politics or whatnot,
but that's obviously highly unlikely to happen.
That's fascinating to me because I guess I agree with the premise that I wish
college could be that.
Right.
And then on the other hand,
when I go to these schools and I see so many kids engaged in the things that
we're talking about,
I always leave incredibly inspired because I'm like,
oh,
you guys are at least awake to these issues,
but I see your point.
It's like if they could be in a weird way,
if they could be insulated from them a little bit to,
to get to deeper learning of the foundational things,
maybe that would be better.
But
yes,
Aristotle and content,
Shakespeare and Milton's commerce,
I mean language that is so sensual,
that is just of,
of almost terrifying eroticism.
They're not going to come across this later.
Uh,
and so I'm grateful to the fact that when I was in college,
I was an Acolyte of deconstruction.
Alas,
I spent way too much time trying to plow my throat.
Why?
Way through La metrology blocked by Jack Derrida and you know,
reading Lacan Jay and Paul demand,
which was a grotesque waste of time.
But multiculturalism hadn't hit yet,
right?
So I was in college in the 70s,
so we read the cannon without anybody thinking to complain about gonads and
Melanin.
So I could,
I could rate the best literature.
Right?
Who Cares?
It didn't come up.
It's amazing.
Now you'd think that,
oh,
this is the first thing you ask about a book.
You know,
well,
do I see myself reflected there?
No.
Okay,
therefore,
I'm not going to read it.
You know,
please do not expose me to a writer that is going to take me out of myself,
which is something that renaissance humanists craved and yearned for.
So anyway,
um,
uh,
the whole gender thing,
the manuals,
there was a past president of the American physics society put out a call to
members to nominate for physics prizes and to put on panels,
females,
just the most egregious,
blatant discarding of a meritocratic principle,
something that is irrelevant to physics.
So this is everywhere.
Uh,
and I just reject it completely.
And the campus idea that females are at risk of rape culture on campus is
equally ludicrous.
If,
if these statistics that the campus rape industry had been throwing around for
the last 10 15,
20 years will remotely accurate one to four to one to five
sexually assaulted during their time on campus.
That is a crime rate that is unseen around the globe.
Detroit as our most violent city,
all four of the FBI's violent index felonies,
which is murder,
rape,
aggravated assault and robbery.
You put all of those together,
you get a 2% violent crime rate.
Wow.
Rape is like 0.1% of the population.
Now obviously the campus thing is over four years.
Even.
So you,
you can never,
you cannot possibly get to one in 41 five.
If that were the case,
we would have seen a mass exodus of females from coed universities decades ago.
These highly sophisticated mothers who are right now in Manhattan paying $200 an
hour to prep their girl taught to get into the most prestigious pre k to set
them on the path to some ivy league.
They would be demanding single sex education.
You would not see on every Saturday night the girls that Uva trouping down rugby
road to the frats and less girls are stupid.
And they do not,
they're not strong women together and there's rape going on and they're not a
warning each other,
which I'm willing to entertain that as an explanation.
But what I'm not willing to entertain as the explanation that there is a
epidemic of sexual assault and females are simply like,
I dunno,
they're accepting it or something.
It's just,
it's very bizarre.
So what do you make of how as the intersectional pyramid that is,
yeah.
You know,
based on these varying levels of what I would see or perceive depression,
I just say real oppression,
that they constantly are talking about racism and bigotry and yet they seem to
be the ones enforcing it.
So I think the best example of this is what's happened over the last couple of
months with the women's march where it became very clear that many of the
leaders were either antisemites themselves or seriously embracing of
antisemites.
And yet these are the same people who would tell you that,
you know,
everyone else is a bigot and a racist.
And the rest of it,
I guess this is just the natural outcome of this.
Well,
it's hilarious.
I love it.
I mean,
I love the internal seen struggles on the left,
right?
It's,
it's hilarious.
It's a comedy actually.
And I always wonder,
you know,
when x left does get called out for bigotry or racism,
does it make them ever think,
well gee,
you know,
I've been calling everybody else a racist.
I know I'm not.
These are false claims.
Maybe the other people that conservatives aren't as well,
you know,
so I don't know if the New York Times has called out or even people who I really
respect.
I mean,
Nicholas Christakis at Yale,
he's a,
he's a wonderful,
serious scholar,
but he is a man of the left,
you know,
and,
and even after he was got eaten by this month,
right?
So he was mob for three hours by students cursing at him in the most vile
language.
It's just the most shocking instantiation of the cultural revolution of these
students that have been just fed their victimology for,
for the last 16 years.
And nobody daring to expect of them.
Civil behavior.
I hope I totally get this right,
but at this moment where these kids are screaming at him at Yale,
one of the girls screaming at him screams who hired you?
And it turns out that she was on the board that helped hire him.
Oh,
I remember that.
That's how bananas,
the whole thing.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Um,
but shouting,
you know,
you are disgusting and it just,
it was unbelievable.
But he,
even after this happened,
it's sort of unfortunate.
He penned a submissive to the student body,
still wanting to confirm his progressive bone a few days and saying,
well of course I understand that for minority students at Yale,
you know,
this is a struggle which is be us.
No,
no students,
no student at Yale is in a struggle for psychological safety or an anti I haven
from racism.
Yale is again,
it is the most progressive environment,
new ministry.
So,
so you know what we've seen with Bret Weinstein and and whatnot,
they now are realizing they're making broader uh,
affiliation.
Yeah.
Well it's funny I bring,
when I do stand up now,
I usually bring one of the IDW crew with me.
You should,
you should join me for one of them.
I love what I bring bread on several times and most of my audience now is
libertarian or Conservative,
old school liberal.
And he's still described himself as a progressive and they love him.
And,
and even though there's a,
there's an absolute disagreement on plenty of the issues and we get into all of
it from climate change to everything else.
The audience cheers and applauds him.
And I always tell him,
I go,
Bro,
you know,
you do know that we couldn't get five progressive's to show up anywhere for us.
Right.
So that does tell you something about,
about the tolerant crew.
Uh,
alright,
moving on from hot hot button to hot button next.
We're in a little bit of a time as you do today.
Um,
let's talk about immigration because this is obviously the thing at the moment.
What is your stance on immigration?
Well,
I think low skilled mass immigration is not a good thing for this country.
I think it's absolutely a country's prerogative to define who comes into the
country.
It is not for people outside of the country to make a de facto immigration
policy by their decisions to come into the country illegally.
And,
uh,
you know,
the left,
we'll not talk about the effect on Americans' wages.
It's,
it's quite bizarre.
You know,
Cesar Chavez,
the farm worker organizer,
was completely against illegal immigration because he realized that it undercuts
the wages of,
of,
of American Hispanics and blacks,
Barbara Jordan,
a black congressman in [inaudible] 94 chair to immigration panel,
totally against the levels of low skilled immigration.
We had saying it's,
it's affecting America's working classes the hardest.
Uh,
and I think that we're bringing in a culture that is not in our current
environment with its monolithic flows from the Central American Mexico.
It's not assimilating.
And what I've been reporting on a for a decade now is the downward assimilation
of the second third generation of Spanish into an underclass culture.
You know,
the conservative happy face narrative is Hispanic family values.
Well,
Hispanics have the second highest out of wedlock childbearing booth after
blacks,
it's about 71% of all black children are born to single parents with Hispanics
is 53%.
That's really high.
When Daniel Patrick Moynihan wrote his extraordinarily present a alarm about
black family breakdown in 1965 and he said as long as so many black boys are
being raised without fathers,
we are not going to close the economic gap.
We are not going to make further progress on civil rights because these boys are
not being socialized.
At that point,
the black out of wedlock birth rate was 23% Moynahan thought that was a crisis.
Right now it's 71% for blacks and for Hispanics.
It's twice that.
I'll never take a an opportunity not to discuss Daniel Patrick Moynihan for a
second,
but so where are the good liberals on this or are they just gone or is it what
you just referred to before?
Which is they know what happens when they've called everyone else racist for so
long so then they just cower away and disappear.
I mean I suspect it's some version of that cause I've kind of lived through it
myself.
Yeah.
Where are they on this being immigration or on out of like the family?
Yes.
Great.
Well on almost everything we've discussed here so far.
Where are the,
where are the good liberals of today?
Well,
again,
they will not talk about behavior.
That is that,
that is the dividing line.
Liberal Moynahan could,
he could say,
look at there are behavioral at this point from here on out we're going to see
predominantly behavior.
Not that obviously in the 60s there was still just egregious racism,
but,
but it was possible to say,
although,
you know,
even back then he was immediately turned into a pariah.
So things weren't so great back then.
It was just mobbed.
And he,
that,
that report which could have,
if it had been embraced and brought into the public discourse would have meant
that we weren't here today,
uh,
talking and having to write these phony narratives about the fact that we still
have this achievement gap and crime gap and incarceration gap.
Uh,
I don't know.
I think,
again,
I think people feel very uncomfortable,
uh,
with the continuing racial divide and they've somehow have lost any confidence
in saying to blacks,
you have agency and it's not all our fault.
So before we skew too far off the immigration thing,
then how do we do this?
Right?
How,
how do we actually do it?
Right.
It seemed right.
Like right now as it stands,
we're sort of between,
either you want a wall and protectionism,
let's say,
or you want open borders.
There seems to be very little in between that,
even though I think probably 80% of us,
if not,
if not 95% of us want something that's much more in between those two things.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean the,
the bromide is,
well,
we need comprehensive immigration reform.
You know,
that that's there.
The safe harbor that you can say on this,
I suppose,
I mean,
comprehensive immigration reform is basically code for amnesty for Daca,
for the dreamers,
and usually a higher levels of,
of family and chain,
low skilled immigration.
I,
I've written for will,
we also need eVerify we need to,
you know,
have employers have to mandatorily check the work papers are just very easy.
It's instantaneous.
They do that.
They get a safe harbor against any kind of liability.
Uh,
but I th I think frankly,
seeing these caravans,
seeing the,
the mobs storming border patrol,
throwing rocks,
trying to scale the fences,
uh,
I'm in favor of a wall.
You know,
the only reason to oppose a wall is because you think it works.
That's why the liberals don't want it.
Uh,
they,
you know,
if they think it's so superfluous,
we put it up,
you know,
what the hell.
But they actually do think it will be effective.
And that's why they don't want it.
Uh,
but I think again,
we need to have,
be able to talk about,
uh,
what low skilled the Po,
the fiscal costs that this mass,
low skilled poverty culture that we are importing is imposing on the American
tax payer.
Whether it's through schools,
you know,
the,
all of the,
again,
I see this at the Berrendo middle school in Pico Rivera,
all of the counselors trying to get these kids that are getting sucked into gang
culture to try and keep them on their feet.
Uh,
the,
the health care costs.
You know,
now you have demographic change so much in California.
You have California saying we're going to have full health care for illegal
immigrants,
mayor de Blasio in New York,
full tax payers,
subsidize healthcare for illegal immigrants.
If the politics keeps changing this way,
that's going to be more and more.
And um,
I dunno,
you know,
a lot of Americans,
some Americans understand that this is just extraordinarily burdensome on our
society.
Yeah.
All right.
We only have about 10 minutes left.
Okay.
That's everything that everything we've been talking about is,
is sort of exactly what the diversity delusion is all about.
Yeah.
Um,
but if I had to pick one thing to,
to end on here,
out of the book,
what,
what should we go with here?
Because I could do,
I could do 20 more topics with you about all of this,
but these things are all so interestingly linked together obviously.
Well I would say the diversity mania,
the,
the sort of equation of the diversity mania,
which is present now both in universities and abroad outside of is a race and
gender.
The most important things about the self I completely disagree with.
I can tell you being female is not an accomplishment.
It is not a particularly interesting status as far as I'm concerned.
Uh,
most important thing about the self
discrimination based on those characteristics is the defining feature of
American society.
See,
Ta-nehisi coats the American academic idle and the idol of the establishment,
uh,
who says that destroying the black body is the very essence of America.
And third,
that any lack of proportionality of race and gender in any institution is by
definition the result of sexism and racism.
That idea now it defines university culture,
but it is now spreading into the sciences.
That's what I think is the most concerning and the most amazing because a lot of
optimists,
the people who want to see,
you know,
all this is fine.
There's all these firewalls,
the firewalls,
whether it's the free market,
it's corporations,
they'll never do this or it's science and the scientist are never going to be
taken care of.
You know,
they'll never taken over by identity politics wrong.
The National Science Foundation is spending billions of taxpayer dollars funding
gender studies professors to study intersectionality and microaggressions in
engineering.
And math.
This is insane.
Uh,
you have Google,
you know,
firing engineers who dare to challenge the feminist orthodoxy.
I have worked out,
I'm collecting a series of natural experiments,
testing the discrimination hypothesis when it comes to gender,
because again,
we look at Google and we see 20% female engineers at Google and other high tech
firms.
The diversity explanation is that's because Google's gatekeepers are sexist.
They are simply unable to spot engineering talent when it comes with female
gonads.
So what we need to test the discrimination of hypothesis are institutions with
no gatekeepers that are wide open.
And I'm collecting examples of these and what they show is that there are
natural differences between males and females when it comes to appetite for
competition.
Drive and yes,
high and math skills.
Wikipedia,
blind editing.
It's open to anybody.
There are no gatekeepers.
Anybody can edit or write a Wikipedia entry.
50,
50 men and women
come on down.
13%.
Females,
the,
the female entries are really weak.
Nobody's,
nobody's keeping them out.
I noticed this where scrabble championships,
nobody's females predominate among casual,
uh,
amature home scrabble players.
There's never been a female scrabble championship,
uh,
spelling,
no.
Does the,
the,
uh,
geography bees,
the winners are males.
It goes on and on and on.
History.
Bees,
the winners are males.
These are things without gatekeepers.
The fact of this silicon valley,
the drive that we see to create these startups,
you guys in the intellectual dark web are predominantly male.
Uh,
that's not that.
There are not individual females out there with as much competitive drive,
as much empire building.
Let's take risks.
But one of the things that God,
James Damore fired from Google for his infamous 10 page memo suggesting that
there may be nondiscriminatory reasons for the lack of 50,
50 gender parity at Google.
He talked about some of the big five personality traits and he used this phrase,
neuroticism.
And to the late,
you're,
this sounded very offensive.
Yeah.
And he said,
females are more neurotic.
This is a common term in psychology.
This has been around for decades.
That's one of the big five traits.
Right?
And it turns out that females are more risk averse and they worry more.
And there might be biological and yeah.
Horrible reasons for this.
Yeah.
So it's interesting,
I'm sure you know about this,
but,
um,
over the last couple months where Jordan and I have been traveling,
we went to Sweden and now everyone on the left and all the socialists,
they always pointed Sweden as the place where they're doing everything right.
In Sweden and Sweden,
which has done egalitarianism.
Right?
Right.
There's no doubt about it.
They have been completely equal men and women.
Well now they've found out that for whatever reason,
men still want to be engineers and women's still want to be nurses.
Right?
So now they ran the experiment properly and that they made a truly egalitarian
society.
But the postmodernist and the leftist and the progressive's won't let them take
the results of the experiment that they did.
Right.
And now they're trying to rejigger the society again.
And it's,
it's just absolutely.
Okay.
Incredible.
It's incredible.
And again,
if there's,
if there's more females than males in an institution,
that's fine.
And let me just finish that.
You know,
with the,
with the conservative to liberal ratio in academia,
if you point that out to,
to the liberals in academia that,
that let you know in some faculties you have a hundred to one liberal to
conservative ratio.
What they will say is,
well,
a conservatives are just not interested in these fields or they're not as smart,
right.
Explanations that they will not,
except for why females gravitate towards more to hands on relational,
human centered work and they're,
they're just not as interested in,
uh,
perhaps being coders at 2:00 AM with cold pizza in some ugly computer science
lab that the Geeks,
the science geeks are predominantly males and they're probably on the spectrum.
So what,
get over it?
Who Cares?
Damn well.
All right.
You're super
busy.
So I,
I'm for all right,
we're going to do this again for sure because I feel like we just got warmed up
here.
Great.
But let's end on gimme something positive out of this.
But for the people that see all this that are truly worried about it are
emailing me every day that care about these conversations.
What are the signs that we might be getting?
Some wins.
You are that enough people are starting to wake up to this craziness.
Well,
your audience I think,
I mean there really are people out there,
the universities,
people are operating under terrified silence.
I hear from professors,
I hear from faculty.
It is unbelievable.
Yeah,
it's like styles.
He's just like,
it's like it's Germany or Russia.
People are afraid to speak in a university,
which purports to be the model of human discourse.
But there are people that are pushing back against it and all I can say is we
are not going to beat this thing and less we push back against the narrative
that any disparities in representation or due to racism and sexism,
as long as that narrative wins the push for quotas,
the destruction of scientific meritocracy is going to continue,
and China is going to end up whooping our ass when it comes to technological
innovation.
Because when it comes to science,
they care about only one thing.
Can you do the engineering?
Okay.
Very strange.
The people who are obsessed with our differences seem to want us to be the same
more than anybody else.
Right.
The garbage velvety.
It's been the prize for Heather.
I'm sorry this was so quick and we're going to do it again for sure.
And for more on Heather,
you can follow her on Twitter
at h m d at am I
[inaudible].